[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live our little
podcast loyaltygaming.net
and who is this far gentleman that we
have in the realm of pax west today hi
my name is jason parks i'm ceo of ro2
entertainment right and what is this
game that we are talking about right now
we're talking about aeolia it just came
out yesterday it is a hands first vr
game five to seven hours long
wow let's take a look at it now so again
hands first vr game
for those completely unfamiliar
what is the background of aeolia
aola comes from an original ip of our
company go to entertainment where
we are taking music theory instruments
note names everything that encompasses
music and we turn that into lands people
ecosystem game mechanics storyline art
so it's one giant universe last year we
released our first game ionia it's all
about saving wildlife in a giant musical
jungle here you're fighting a storm akin
to climate change and desert vacation
where you are conga and using your
musical superpowers as a modus you're
capable of saving the pool wow one thing
i'm saying off the bat is just like the
the terminal how intuitive the hand
movement seen and how interactive it is
with the environment a lot of control a
lot of i'm invoking a lot of like i feel
very powerful in this world can you tell
me about that am i off i say that no
you're absolutely right
in aeolia it's all about this very
intuitive hand tracking system that
allows you to do everything from jump 40
feet in the air
like love of
being able to teleport yourself above
giant skyscrapers really able to use
uh
these musical superpowers to
solve puzzles of these ancient ruins and
be able to start to bring the energy
back to a desolated world so that is you
were mentioning you feel real powerful
in this game you literally use your
hands literally to
save the world awesome awesome what was
some of the inspirations behind what got
you guys thinking it is it's a very
unique type of title in devices oh thank
you
it's been 10 years in the making
we all most of our team started at
berkeley college of music we made a
music video where we brought 90
musicians from 90 different countries
together wrote a song of peace we had
citizens of countries that were at war
with each other at the same table write
music
so this really spurred this idea of a
collaborative universe based around
vibration and music education and theory
in this like a world that we had all as
90 musicians from these countries
lived together and it brought us
together you know and harmonized us we
then brought that to a giant epic story
that years ago was taught and and shared
on stage and in music videos but very
easily lent itself to making vr games
now here's the thing i didn't even
realize the the music connection is as
deep as it is like
well i'm assuming like how did how
difficult was it to translate that to vr
uh
it actually it was
quite easy to
make a world based around what we were
thinking right so originally the idea
being
uh i have someone on stage right and
they're representing the land of aeolia
and they have giant taiko drums and
they're hitting the music and all the
violinists are playing and they're all
representing a different land yet unity
brings them all together through the
music so we took that a step further and
we're like in a virtual world
what what can we do we actually can
store we can create some of the greatest
storytelling possible by putting you
into the into the heart and mind of what
we always try to express through live
shows and music videos and so it just
became this world that we were
evolved around and ultimately
turned what we were representing on
stage and the powers that you have in
game and ultimately told the story that
we've been telling for ten years that's
awesome as you can see lord bill is
telling the story with his hand look at
that look at this man putting it
together he's conducting right now he's
conducting this amazing it feels like a
conductive
movement it flows really clean that is
awesome and again
berkeley college
like you see the influence man so again
these years of development you put this
thing together you bring it to vr like
now how close are we to the finish line
how are we getting there well in terms
of the game yes best part about it it
released yesterday
yesterday on what device
on oculus quest 2 marketplace yes yes
yes
but look it's so cool to see vr continue
to transcend and to see ideas that kind
of jump outside the 2d space into the
daily space and it's such a unique
concept and it absolutely looks gorgeous
to be honest with you cannot wait for us
to try again just released
yesterday so go get that go support and
any any other future things you want to
say to someone who
completely might be on the fence
what's the cell what's the pitch
well if you already know us from ionia
right here all right this was our first
title last year this title was focused
more around
first-time vr users casual vr users
people who maybe don't know how to use
vr very well and it is a 90 minute
immersive experience slash interactive
game it was a combination very akin to
vader immortal oh i love playing yeah so
that that was ionian right
now is a completely different piece what
we focus on is something for more of the
the gamer who likes action inventory who
likes puzzles right who is who wants to
spend five to seven hours figuring out a
game that's not easy it is not easy to
finish this game and quite honestly
we'll have some of the best hand
tracking you've ever experienced we
believe we have best hand tracking for
large terrain right so one thing we love
to do is climb ultimately to uh jump to
turn and more importantly like we
mentioned earlier a very fantastic
locomotion system that nobody else has
we have gestures that allow you to
intuitively flow and move around so if
you want to try and push what hand
tracking can do with hands 2.0
this is the game this is the game doing
you are selling me
i'm embarrassed i got to get tired i
want you i got to get the yo i got to i
got to get in the backlog and play these
games this looks absolutely fantastic
and this again i'm noticing this was on
psvr stevie and metaquest 2 this debuts
on metaquest too look we care that way
an absolute pleasure
one last thing oh please please do it
five percent of all proceeds for both
games go to relevant non-profits we are
the only vr game that has a public
partner a public nonprofit partnership
with the uh if you know steve irwin yes
right his foundation is run by his
family the wildlife warriors five
percent of our game goes to them so
you're doing a good thing for the realm
man absolute pleasure you sold me
fantastic brother this looks haze on vr
adventure very intuitive
puzzles
but look it's out now go check that out
i love podcasting.net approve aeolia
bill we're feeling it yeah i got to be
our face
it was birthday i'm bad hey yolia check
it out
right now
on
metaquest
[Music]
you